it's head to naturebox.com/tyler right
now to get 50% off your first box shows
awesome brought to you by headspace go
to headspace calm right now and download
the free app and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation at headspace calm /oe that's
Head space.com slash Joey and the show
is brought to you by Donna calm go to
audit calm and use code word Church to
get 10% off all the great optimization
products like alpha brain and new mood
what's the story I'm here I'm here I'm
high as [ __ ] that's what we're supposed
to do it's a beautiful Wednesday
February 3rd it's [ __ ] up when you
were talking about meditation you know
Lee in this [ __ ] started with me like in
1990 ok I didn't know what Depression
was I had heard about depression but now
thinking about what America is this I
don't know if this even was depression
this is maybe a form of unhappiness you
know I'm saying oh so what how old are
you 1990 1990 I'm [ __ ] 28 years old
or some [ __ ] hey 3 & 7
I'm 27 years old I'm married I got a kid
roofing I'm making an OK living I'm
busting my ass mm-hmm I was a flat
roofing during the week what's that now
listed will you go up on the roof and
you tear 40 squares off and then you put
insulation and then you put a rubber and
then you put ballast in which is rocks
and you then you flash it you come back
and flash it every three days you go
back and flash it in the afternoon you
know which is tighten up all the seals
run the pipes in the air-conditioning
huh okay and all that [ __ ] but for the
most part we were a four-man crew
five-man crew that was doing [ __ ] 40
squares too hot roofs on that school on
that roof since 1920 plus an additional
wooden roof I mean it was crazy we cut
through it and then [ __ ] pull it off
and then later on the insulator
lay down on some mother's [ __ ] down in
and lay down the rubber and then ballast
it okay so what uh just wouldn't why
didn't you just play it on top of all
the other stuff all the other really
fresh air and the roof underneath was
faulty so you don't want to put good
[ __ ] on top of bad [ __ ] they wanted you
to re-roof the [ __ ] thing it had been
there for 50 [ __ ] years the roof
there's no building the building was in
great shape
but you know something was [ __ ]
missing me something was missing for the
first time my life went my head had hit
a wall by 27 28 in my head and I hit a
wall I didn't know what to do so it's
funny that you bring a meditate in that
summer I did everything I went back to
the Catholic Church I signed up for
confirmation class at the age of 30 I'm
gonna tell information class there's a
bunch of 13 12 year olds so you didn't
do that when you were 13 no they drew us
up because of the lubes Christopher it
was a bunch of people North Bergen they
like yeah that 1 o'clock on Fridays and
you had two choices either you stayed in
school or you went to [ __ ] catholic
catholicism
CD or something CCP guess what even the
Jews signed up they get the [ __ ] out of
this hell yeah - I was a [ __ ] cat
Catholic [ __ ] just to live with the
enemy's thinking that's when the Jews
but right there so they all were like
Bill Belichick they all went over buying
on the cash or they went over to the
Catholics just to see what these
[ __ ] are thinking 2,000 years
since we stabbed Jesus we might have to
get back to the [ __ ] party so even now
right here in Studio City the daycare
with my wife was thinking of taking the
baby there's a lot of Jewish kids and
it's a Christian school because the
daycare so good there's a waiting list a
they you know who gives a [ __ ] they
probably got him in the back [ __ ]
and I'm taking pictures and shits and
pictures to Vegas or some [ __ ] and we
don't even know it that you gotta be
careful but anyway that was [ __ ]
unhappily I didn't know what to do what
do you mean on hat because it's it's
funny thick I had a conversation like
this today so like what do you when you
say unhappy it's not like you're sad
it's not like you
but whatever you do within your life at
that time just ain't feeling right even
the coke it wasn't feeling right my wife
was so [ __ ] up on the inside that
nothing felt right when I say on the
inside let's let's get time for basis I
had a beautiful wife I had a beautiful
baby
I just bought a condo everything that
you were supposed to want a truck we had
a car we weren't rich I mean we didn't
have $50,000 in the bank we had a couple
grants but in my world where I had come
from five years earlier there was no
bank account bank account will get open
to get closed a week later than I'd
robbed the thing I was the only person
who ever robbed his own bank accounts
he's [ __ ] ridiculous so if in my world
that was [ __ ] just perfect I had a job
I had security but in my world
how were you happy for any of it cuz you
said it you said the wedding you want
but not a [ __ ] thing I loved that
little girl with all my heart
that was it that's the only thing that
was keeping me together if I would have
just been married without that little
girl at the time I would have taken a
plane and god [ __ ] what's that Bruce
Springsteen story he went out for a pack
of cigarettes and never came back I want
to pull one of those Louis L'Amour
[ __ ] novels and I can't lie to you
because nothing felt right the job
didn't feel right the money didn't feel
right I just didn't feel right it was
too clean it was too perfect it was what
I wanted but I didn't really want that
and could you tell anyone or what didn't
anyone think you're crazy I thought what
I was going crazy I didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do with my life I was so unhappy
here I'm picking up it's 1990 and I'm
picking up eight bills a week roof and
flat cash cash no taxes which is really
12 at 13
yeah and I was picking up another
fifteen on the weekends doing the roof
by myself and another guy ripping it
down on Friday night Stas stocking it on
Friday going back there Saturday morning
early putting the first roof on ripping
the other one off stocking that coming
back on Sunday
putting that roof on flashing it getting
home by dinner at six o'clock hanging
out with the baby and the [ __ ]
so-called wife and getting up the next
morning at 5:30 and doing it all over
again you had to get up at 5:30 every
other being that'd be in downtown Denver
by 7:00 a.m. from Boulder [ __ ] that
worked and he gave us a bonus he made us
a deal in October
like in midnight old B came to us and he
says if we finish this roof out of here
everything clean the day before
Thanksgiving we got like a hundred grand
bonus and I chopped that up I take half
of the company and chop that up but
until then we got to work every day and
we look for me go [ __ ] yeah yeah for ten
grand and we worked every [ __ ] day I
mean it would snow a foot of snow we'd
shovel that snow wait till the Sun came
up and get to work and this is how good
we were some we got for the point where
we got so good as a crew that some days
we'd started eleven and we'd still
finished by 3:30 when the truck would
come with the gravel because the truck
would come at 3:30 and he didn't give no
he come at 3:00 o'clock every day with
you know I don't know how many tons of
gravel like stone like and that's we put
on the roof and that's what you put on
the roof to keep the roof on the roof
huh so he didn't give a [ __ ] like you
couldn't waive it I'm going we we ain't
gonna be ready for 10 minutes that
didn't fly he'd take and make a u-turn
and leave so that's how good that crew
got we had a young white dude from
Jersey a cop the next guy he was trying
to be a cop he had two Irish
laborers from New Jersey because the
company was based out of Jersey
he had just brought him back to Colorado
we had Mike robot he used to call in
here who calls him with a book about
knives and [ __ ] and also was a dear
friend of mine right and we had this 60
year old oh guy that his name was Jim
and he had no teeth I used to torment
Jim every damn I loved you we used to
[ __ ] Jim [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] and we torments him
was that the guy who brought on the food
he used to bring his own food we used to
try to steal from him he tell us to go
[ __ ] himself so I took a [ __ ] in a bag
and squished it like a brownie one day
and gave her hey anybody want a brownie
and I knew he was a sucker for brownie
I'll take it and he came over and
grabbed that brownie and I walked away
knowing it was a piece of [ __ ] know that
I had put together crumpled it up in
those days I used to eat Harvest granola
every [ __ ] day ever since I got out
of [ __ ] the joint every day I went to
the harvest restaurant and I had Swiss
granola every day he understand me I
never ate eggs again oh you should
rethink for three [ __ ] years that's
all I ate was Swiss granola oh my god
which was frozen vanilla yogurt which
will kill you right there but I didn't
give a [ __ ] with granola with
raspberries blueberries pineapples and
bananas mix that [ __ ] gumbo of
death up and I eat that every breakfast
and they had the harvest iced tea it was
a vegan place but delicious they used to
have vegan [ __ ] gazpacho you think I
sparked a vegan already like that I
guess so like a [ __ ] Mexican soup or
some [ __ ] yeah it's like tomato I guess
it's usually fish in it seafood but the
point the [ __ ] story that I'm getting
to it
right I mean I didn't know what was
eating me alive me I knew that I just
knew that I was [ __ ] miserable so now
I go down the Sacred Heart where I got
married I sign up for confirmation
classes
it makes my confirmations to get the
Holy Spirit in me you think that [ __ ]
work that should make me feel [ __ ]
worse than I already did why
[ __ ] those I walked around for
another two months and a buddy of mine
recommended that I go meditate at a
place called Naropa Institute okay and
boulders for all these [ __ ] hippies
hanging out these little trust fund kids
that are really dynamite kids and they
get stones and how it was really turned
on to the rope it was one of my buddies
worked in a [ __ ] kitchen at Naropa
okay and he worked there as an employee
okay the guy the only thing he worked
hard and when everybody else is calling
in sick he was going to work every day
and the guy trusted the guy gave him the
keys and they just kept this trust kept
growing up between my buddy my buddy was
a bartender but he also did this job
three days a week he likes he was a
vegan
this place was a vegan place and he was
a vegan cook him and his girlfriend were
both vegan cooks well not him his
girlfriend with both vegans okay and one
day the guy came in he was a minim 9/8
this place is yours
wow I don't know there was some money
exchanged but it was just a break-even
type deal and my buddy had to work two
years or sons to make the long back and
that was it he owns the place now he
owns like three of those places Lenny
Martinelli in Boulder Colorado and they
do cuz I guess I meditated for years and
my dad might my dad did I had my brother
and I do it and we went to one we went
it's like an Ayurvedic place on it
doesn't sound like what he was doing but
the head like you had meditation and all
like healthy food
yeah well this Monday since that place
had walking meditation yeah yeah that's
how you say you have a little walking
meditation and the first time I learned
there and they had like these mats what
really happened was it what that wasn't
at Naropa this was up a park you had to
walk up this apart named Chautauqua
okay and up there they have this these
little white monks these little [ __ ]
rich guys they put turbans on and they
take the shirts off and they stopped
putting deodorant on and they stink like
[ __ ] death and you go in and you'd
walk meditate and the first time I went
in there Lee I swear to god I smell feet
so much in my nose because you have to
breathe in three
knows where I am the foot was stuck like
how it's not like 20 different sets of
feet at once and it got stuck in the
middle of my [ __ ] nose I was getting
sick in there cuz there was no actually
I didn't have panic attacks then I just
was getting busy like I had to get the
[ __ ] out there from the smaller feet
that's what my nose was still good and
like it's no it was very sensitive and
[ __ ] and like I went to one time and I
kind of got sick I snot like armpit and
patchouli juice and all that [ __ ] put
together then I went back and then I
started going back on the Mondays and I
really enjoyed it except for the smell
of feet that's maybe why my hatred of
[ __ ] feet and jiu-jitsu at first
that's good
have you ever done hot yoga no but that
dude got in trouble a little perverted
[ __ ] Hindu did you see him
no he comes out [ __ ] back room that's
the yoga yeah yeah we got sued last week
for [ __ ] torture and sex and [ __ ] him
he's like no no I'm gonna take some that
dudes a filthy [ __ ] Hindu and I love
Hindus but that dude even Hindus get
madam this dude walks around with them
curry feet with a bikini on people
sweating he's got that [ __ ] hunger
juice coming out of his toes and [ __ ] I
have people these [ __ ] white chicks
that go down and suck his dick they
should be shot long and those little
white chicks here's white chicks it's
just coming how is the old
oh he's [ __ ] older than that but
these [ __ ] white chicks go down and
they're like oh my god he changed my
life hunga you know me [ __ ] he
touched me you know and all this [ __ ]
where nobody else has touched me and end
up suckers they end up sucking that
carried dick and then [ __ ] you know
you gotta live with that the rest of
your life you blew that [ __ ] carry
dick dude after a hot Bikram [ __ ]
yoga his boss smelt like [ __ ] curdled
milk and there you are [ __ ] uh-huh
yeah he touched me inside get the [ __ ]
out here you [ __ ] Mook that I swear
to god I went what happened was about
maybe it had to be five six years ago
longer cuz we were still living in
Hollywood me and my wife got invited to
a party mark Bennington photography cool
[ __ ] always did my headshots I'm
still tired with him he lives in Jersey
City
if you need headshots can i attack me if
you live in the New Jersey area I'll
hook you up and mark men until he's
[ __ ] death his headshots will book
you work even without auditions like
that's how strong his headshots are but
Bano been live men wasn't all that
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
him me and Bennington got along because
of music but on the other side he was
just whacked out of his mind he hung out
with these wacky Hollywood people and
one of them was a chick who was a yoga
chick dog I was so [ __ ] high when I
walked in there like I got high by
mistake as my wife was driving and this
[ __ ] gave me a beating about yoga that
my wife was getting me into yo yeah
because you did yoga weight and my wife
is really getting me into yoga which I
wasn't doing it right
like now I'm thinking about going to
where she goes but I don't want to blow
up a spot so there's a spot over here I
saw that gives you like 10 yoga's for 10
bucks or something weird
it's and have a beginner class yoga and
you're going in you really breathe and
I'm thinking about it you lose weight
doing yoga they say yes they say yes I
saw that little Chinese guy in the video
he couldn't walk he started doing yoga
dopey guy yeah next thing you know he's
[ __ ] doing jumping jacks and he's
[ __ ] running and I don't know this
well that was hard I did that class I
got confused I went to yoga for a while
and I thought I was a little loose
weight and I'd break the sweat and stuff
but it's not a sweat addition to the
workouts yeah it's like a [ __ ]
stretch and get your blood going to
those places and it makes your back
strong and your breathing if you're
breathing right like now I'm getting the
breathing better you know listen I could
lose 100 pounds I just need to [ __ ]
get my nose cleaned up yeah I just
Dave Dave told me three years ago Joey I
can tell just by your breathing you
knows you're not getting the effects
oxygen you know you did blow for 30
years what'd you expect
oh how good you think your nose is I
don't smell half the time I don't know
why this [ __ ] really there's some days I
don't taste nothing I just leave it
because what the [ __ ] one of my options
it was good yesterday that's [ __ ] up
so it's because that's what happened to
sage Northcutt last week he said he had
a
really bad flu and when he was on his
back he just couldn't breathe you can't
breathe the pressure goes to your head
it's like going into the airplane I've
got to bring two [ __ ] things and
pills on a plane just in case I forget
like right tonight when I go home like
I'm already packed but yesterday I
already put two new [ __ ] nose sprays
in the back my travel back when I bring
him the plane with the computer and the
notebook and the Pens in it yeah so what
what is that what is the doctor gonna do
for you that's gonna fix it fix [ __ ]
it really was weird I was watching that
Whitney Houston thing okay the last 24
hours of Whitney Houston's autopsy and
it was they were checking out the body
and what went wrong this is as soon as
you looked at her nose you knew it's a
perforated septum which means my septum
has little holes in it so it's like a
balloon little holes and just really
like if I sniff a lot of it don't go in
where did it go who the [ __ ] knows into
my eyeball that's that's scary so what
are you gonna do that soonish you know
when I get a chance to go over the
[ __ ] Hill you know all this [ __ ] is
over the hill and this traffic over that
[ __ ] hill and it's a scary place in
my world next way I gotta go over the
hill like a [ __ ]
I'm homo next week I got a run over I
got a blood test and I gonna see the
heart doctor I gotta make I'm gonna do
the Tom Rhodes podcast you know I gotta
work next week I got a little meeting
Monday and a lot of action even though
I'm home I got a lot of [ __ ] action
next week next week's real and the
weekend so that's my birthday and the
week after that my boy Michael Dodd
comes on the show for two nights to
break down on the seven [ __ ]
five yeah the 22nd and 23rd I think the
dates are the 24th I got a big time
showcase at the Connelly store at 8:30
so I got three [ __ ] weeks from now
trust me
and these I like it this way this is the
way it's supposed to be not to mention
the baby jiu-jitsu working out riding
you know arguing you know you know but
it's good to be like it's ya know so you
were saying the last three weeks have
been a joy in my [ __ ] heart I'm busy
just being me now put me on a
[ __ ] mission that's what I
enjoy
time that I call you this morning six
and I was already up two hours I had
already written a now on the [ __ ]
half and anger
I just wrote I put together a
proposition I had to do for some people
yeah when I go to work I go to work one
is that coffee and that [ __ ] first
but a doc right that first Du Bois and
you ain't stop master disaster I wanted
to ask you general when you're talking
about feeling a little bit down what did
you feel like when you woke up cuz that
for me was the worst waking up for lucky
the job that I hated waking up and like
dreading the seconds until I got there
at that time I gotta be honest with ya I
hated every work waking moment of the
day because it felt like what I wanted
to do I wasn't doing right it's at the
same time I didn't know what I wanted to
do and that frustrated more that
frustrated me more the thing that saved
me which is I was making Gita's I was
putting together with G this I was doing
a couple bumps from time to time I was
already done with the halfway house I
was running a game on my house at that
point I was running games I figured out
how to get the how to get school loans
you know and do pull up the paperwork
for full time and then take the credits
off and go part-time and keep the money
I was already figuring out [ __ ] I was
already wheeling and dealing and let's
pretend I wasn't snorting blow I would
buy an ounce for eleventh to sell it to
you for eighteen I don't give a [ __ ] you
know my world that's five hundred that's
a final profit for the day let's make it
happen
you got an ounce for eleven hundred Lee
this guy will buy for eighteen let's go
put the money about selling we'll split
the [ __ ] cash just like that we'll
split 250 just like that BAM
nobody goes to jail I know this [ __ ]
jamoke that's awesome
so then when you were saying you finally
focus on comedy did he try to stop doing
that I didn't focus on economy at that
point at that point I was dilly-dallying
with it at that point
I have been put back into the halfway
house
forgetting hi and while I was in the
halfway house my buddy showed me a tape
Andrew Dice Clay and I borrowed the tape
on New Year's Eve and I watched that
tape New Year's Eve when I woke up New
Year's Eve 1991 just something I was
like something's gonna happen
I gotta make it happen I didn't write my
goals I didn't do nothing I kept working
on the [ __ ] roof but when you had
that epiphany did you stop doing all
that other stupid stuff or no not really
no I was I wasn't doing blow I was
selling it all I was trying to do was to
stay ahead of whatever what I've been
trying to do since day one but at this
time I was trying to support a family
and I was serious about the family but I
was still very serious about my [ __ ]
drug life and how I lived that wasn't
gonna stop me that was not gonna stop me
at that age I still had the guns hidden
I still would rob your house if there
was more than 10,000 in there you know I
was just being very careful after I got
out of prison I got very careful I
watched my back a little extra if I saw
something but I thought it could be a
trap I walked away from me you know what
if I [ __ ] lost 7,000 my lost 7,000
but I didn't go for the trap all right
okay I never went for stupid [ __ ]
traps and I kept out of them and then
once I had that tape and I woke up that
day in 91 for about a month I had this
weird feeling that maybe I should try
standup I had this weird feeling like
maybe I should try and stand and people
have been telling you at this point to
try it right 2 3 4 4 people and come to
me and say you should try standup and
I'm like no I'm not gonna do it
but that mornings of January 1st 1991
I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] try stand
up but not gonna tell nobody module I'm
way on time and that was my thought I
had and that thought lasted for about 30
days and then it came back to me what am
I gonna do stand up and it was like I
don't [ __ ] know I don't [ __ ] know
you know I'm too busy I got the kid and
I started making excuses for myself in
my head ah maybe out how go you know in
those days there wasn't the winter that
I wasn't gonna Google how do I start
stand up you just you know what do you
do you go to library I didn't know about
stand-up comedy clubs I thought people
just to stand up on TV you know I really
I knew that people did shows and
individual places but I didn't know
really that there was just standard
comedy clubs like all your time in New
York you've never seen all the [ __ ] no
are you crazy
me and my friends never did that [ __ ]
really see any Murphy at the garden okay
okay so I thought you just woke up one
day when I just heard about stand-up I
thought that one day is that a gun I
hope no one I thought that one day you
woke up you went to some guy's house you
had the material and you got on stage
and there was 200 people there and you
did call me and that was it that was the
whole process that was the whole process
and the only experience I had had with
stand-up that I saw looked at it and I
walked away was Charlie whatever I was
telling you Barnett at Central Park
yeah at Washington Square Park right
then yeah when I saw that I was very
like wow he's doing it outside life
that's how they do it like I was still I
didn't I didn't have a rock
guys I didn't have an idea that you had
to work hard and get on stage every
night and do it for 10 years and I had
no idea I basically thought that you
wrote material and you went to a TV
station and they have a stage and you
went up there and had 200 people in the
audience that's what I really [ __ ]
thought
pathetic I was so I didn't know nothing
February came along at this point I'm
not really working on the rules anymore
I'm basically going to the rules and
bringing them whatever they forgot there
was two or three crews that you were
like the supervisor I was I was the
estimator but part of my job was
materials so in the mornings before I
went an estimated I had to drop
materials off to people go get whatever
they needed
so if I'd have to go to high 72 this
place and gets ashes metal whatever you
know screws drill bits whatever so one
day I went on the job and it snowed but
the Sun was out I'll never forget that
like usually when it snows like it stays
cloudy like an hour but it's not like it
was a Sun shower but it's known [ __ ]
six inches holy [ __ ]
and breakfast was 10 o'clock and I said
you know what guys I'll shovel and on
the way down I'll go over and get you
guys breakfast give me your orders and
in those days there was six of us we all
either container green chilly some days
I just pay for it I get the money when I
went back or and then the next day some
other guy would pay you know we were
really cool about it so I said a little
green chilly to warm us up and something
we I had to order something and I had a
sit okay like I had to sit like it was
those old diners where you had a sit and
that has this the circular stools yeah
yeah oh my god yeah the counter so I was
sitting at the counter and I look over
and there's a [ __ ] newspaper a Rocky
Mountain post or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and then pick it up and I'm scrolling
through this Rocky Mountain [ __ ] post
and in the middle and said how to be a
comedian
just out in the newspaper in the
newspaper like you know the middle of
entertainment like like every paper has
like like you know what happened the
police blotter and then as you get to
the middle of this sale pages women's
bras and Macy's just in the middle right
in the front page of entertainment how
to become a stand-up comic they
interviewed five local guys one
was economy by the name of Andy Payton
I'll never forget that and and that
inside has how to become a comedian go
to an open mic at the Comedy Works in
Denver do this and take a stand-up class
I went with the [ __ ] last one I had
the fear of death what did you think
when he saw that in the paper just like
the answer to your prayer that's crazy
it was crazy it's like God put like that
was crazy I stole the section yeah I
took the section that I put in my pocket
I sat in the car and I looked at it and
it took me about and I'm lying to you
guys because something happened way
before that that really [ __ ] me up I
watched the movie punchline it snowed in
January and I was home and I went for
that movie place and Baldwin and I got
plenty light with Tom Hanks and and
Sally Struthers is no no no Tom Hanks
and Tom Hanks and the chick that was uh
from from the she's old
I mean you won't know what is okay it
was Tom Hanks angel Salazar Damon Wayans
it's called punchline and it's a movie
about a comedy club in Jersey called the
garage
I think the exploits that go in in there
and it also has a contest her name is
Lila and she was though Flying Nun and
that's her name and the thing and and
Tom Hanks is a doctor and he gets thrown
out of medical school so now he's lying
through his parents and he's really
don't stand up at night and it shows him
doing like [ __ ] cancer clinics in the
afternoon for 25 bucks and writing jokes
for people it was really and I watched
it this afternoon my head almost blew up
oh you watch it again this afternoon no
I watched it whatever it snowed and I
couldn't work and I watched it my head
almost blew up I was like holy [ __ ] so
that's what you got to do so I went in
the Yellow Pages I saw dens economy
works that was like oh [ __ ] and I called
him and I said you have an open landing
like Tuesdays I go how do I get on and
they go you got a call the Thursday
before before 4 o'clock whatever the
[ __ ] I never called and then a couple
weeks later I saw that newspaper article
and that really put me over the top so I
saw economy works
I saw these other clubs but the main
thing I saw was a comedy class at the
University of Colorado in Boulder I'm
gonna shred around the corner from my
house I'm in I got stand-up comedy I'm
standing a family class at the college
three Sundays in a row
dirty five [ __ ] dollars Wow
thirty five [ __ ] dollars the guy's
name was Jeff harms and I sat down the
first week I didn't know what to expect
he made this by a book he told us about
stand-up it was a three-hour class on
Sundays the guy was a sweetheart he did
five hours you know he just kept us
fairly we just all sat there like in the
hammered and it was for people who had
fear of public speaking or who won again
to stand up coming so the second Sunday
you had a write material a little bit
with him and think about what you wanted
to do and discuss it with him then the
third Sunday you did a performance and
this was the first time he ever did it
ever before any stage pretty much I had
done it in prison a few times on stage
but I didn't know it was [ __ ] stand
up I thought it was people yelling that
people from a table I know is the other
stand-up family no I don't think you put
it on your resume but that's crazy how
you went to my college actually just had
I started a stand-up comedy major it's
crazy it's [ __ ] crazy it's huge right
now I could teach it I could teach that
[ __ ] because I really know the nuts and
bolts but it was so like that class that
last Sunday as I was leaving he pulled
me aside and he goes I think that you
really have a career in this if you
really want to do this this is just at
that time I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
wanted to do I didn't know if this was
the answer to my unhappiness so what
were you searching for like at the class
like why were you at the class then why
did I take the class yeah I wanted to
see the nuts and bolts and all these I
wanted to know how to let's pretend I
want to know how to you know before I go
to ITT Tech and spend $9,000 on
electrical wiring let me see if I'll
live it even like this [ __ ] right the
$36 $37 I had nothing to do by taking a
class nothing to lose if it was 2000
hello then I got to commit to it but it
was $37 what do I care for three [ __ ]
Sundays of my time I enjoyed it but when
that guy said that to me it [ __ ] up me
a little bit like it was like really and
I started thinking about it thinking
about it thinking about a thing of the
man who when they pulled in the paper
Here I am working 7 2 3 right right
right
roofing and working on the weekends and
that's the meaning and I'm going home
and taking care of a baby with my wife
at the time we're not really genin so
guess what guess what I saw in the
boulder paper and then for doorman at
the comedy club I seen got that job I
went I applied I got a job at night as a
doorman so I had to be there at 7:30 I
seen everybody and then I just stayed
that the door and I had to let everybody
leave and then I get the Kalon go home
that was my job and I watch comedians
how many nights a week uh Tuesday
through Sunday dad goes your marriage
well yeah my marriage was doomed anyway
there goes my marriage I was just trying
to stay ahead but at that time I was so
unhappy I said [ __ ] let me take this
job this is what I want to do let me at
least go in the scene and ask questions
and become friends with these guys
helped him carry their luggage to the
car at that time I do whatever just to
ask you a question and the comments were
very nice to me they answered my
questions or the people are nice to me
and also guess what the [ __ ] lighting
guy in the sound guy quit so they came
to me they're like what are you doing
you want to make them two extra holes
around I'm like it turned out oh I had
to turn on the show and [ __ ] sit here
till the end of my show the volumes
right and we'll pay you for two jobs
thought so then I got there at 7:00 and
I stayed till close and I became friends
with them and I was allowed to have a
drink with the comedians and ask them
and then a week later guess what
happened like the barback quit you were
not the entire staff of the entire tub
though I was the barback
start to show go in the back mixed drink
stock the bar wash glasses mixed drinks
go out close the show clean the barn go
home they took the other don't the door
staff job for me they gave it to one of
the girls to see people take IDs she was
a big little Indian looking [ __ ] she's
about 6 foot 1 400 pounds he didn't [ __ ]
around so Indian like all she was
something with you like Alaskan or
something [ __ ] Himalayan who knows we
had people looking [ __ ] no
because she was very sweet but I did
that and as soon as I did that I was
like [ __ ] this I'm going on stage and
then so for three weeks we say that I
[ __ ] him rough of [ __ ] in May I
started calling economy works like that
mid-april I started calling economy
worse and every week they would call me
you have a spot like cancel all right
I kept cancelling and canceling and
cancer that wasn't ready and my material
wasn't ready I wanted to have 20 minutes
just tons of excuses one after the other
and how many we you were doing three
minutes three minutes that's it but you
wanted to have 20 just in case just you
know just an excuse that's the excuse
comics to tell you well I'm not ready I
want to have an hour before I go up
there just like that you're gonna have a
[ __ ] hour you don't even know how to
write a minute and you know what you
know it's just an excuse to comics that
don't know we'll say it before they go
onstage people other fear we're going
onstage so it was huge fear I had you
know at this time Lee it's not that I
failed at everything
it's like wit everything what was gonna
be [ __ ] different now you know what
was gonna be different was I gonna start
this and then quit Italy I quit
everything from the base in the 6th
grade to my bartending job in the city
to my cook job to my dishwashing job to
my [ __ ] pipe job to my [ __ ]
spackling job I mean I quit I'd be John
what was it gonna be like I was like how
am I gonna [ __ ]
and you actually like consciously
thought I can't quit it I don't want to
quit this like no I didn't even I didn't
I had a wife I had a kid you know I was
on probation
I didn't want my in-laws had given me
this job to teach me how to roof you
know I worked harder than everybody else
I mean let me tell you something one
family gives me a job
I never wanted them to say well your
brother-in-law's lazy so I worked harder
than everybody else I was the first
another job site and the last one to
leave somebody to do something on a
Sunday I got in the truck and did it
just so nobody could ever talk bad about
me on that job site so what time did you
get out of the comedy club though cuz
you see you're waking up at 5:30 one so
you got like three hours of sleep at
night I'm Tanya Lee Lee you think I'm
kidding you and the two lights I didn't
have sleep I'd snort coke so I was no
sleep in my [ __ ] house there was no
[ __ ] sleep what sleep leave ya you
trying to get ahead what who gives a
[ __ ] about crazy but at that time let's
go for another one yeah it's so high
already who gives a [ __ ] that's what
it's all about
okay let's do it ego matter Lee sin man
I'll get it so [ __ ] miserable dad I
didn't know I didn't care I was like
[ __ ] I'll take a chance with this
nonsense you know and that was the and
at that time I was starting to get along
with my wife a little bit she was like
if you do this I'm gonna be so proud of
you and finally they called me and they
were like you're on this Tuesday and I
was like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] me so I
told a couple people to put myself in
the spot okay you following me I told a
few people so I had to put myself in
this spot people go away you performing
they go I'm not telling you but I'm
going up on stage and I drove down for
Comedy Works in Denver I sat in the
audience man and
they came and got me and listen you're
up next and I [ __ ] will up on that
stage and I saw those people and I got a
few laughs I remember like I got a few
laughs not what I anticipated my dream
was to go up there and just destroy them
and people picking me up and he's
cheering and [ __ ] and next thing you
know Disney comes over with a [ __ ]
deal and yeah that's your plan you know
I remember they were doing them they
used to do a lot of contests in those
days a lot of contests in the [ __ ]
early 90s late like bars and clubs no
Johnnie Walker red all these companies
had comedy competitions uh sure not
Schmidt's the one that backs backs had a
comedy competition Charlie Walker red
had a comedy competition you know MBC
them when that Felicia one had economy
competition so a lot of people had
comedy competitions in those days but
NBC had one in Boulder one time you had
to go to this place and and and sign
your name and wait till your calls and
go in a room with two people and I
actually thought we thought I wasn't
going then shunned the judges with my
brilliant material and I'm I did two of
those and how I had he been doing how
many weeks we were walking like oh yeah
I was no walk in there and just razzle
him so hard that they were gonna whisk
me off to Los Angeles give me a show and
I've been living next door the [ __ ]
Brad paid for something like that that's
what I really thought Lee that's how
demented I was at that age and the first
time I went into this room there was two
guys young guys like hey oh yeah hey
what's going on I tried to be cute and
he's go for it and then I [ __ ] just
sat there for three minutes and just
continually said things to make them
hate me more and more and more than that
but when I walked out they were both
pale and they were asking me never like
I could see that they were saying they
were like [ __ ] come back just don't
what were you saying I'm saying these
people
ideally I was doing Godzilla jokes and
Cuban magician jokes who [ __ ] knows
Lee knows what I know it was [ __ ]
terrible that's all I know was just
terrible and then I went to another one
look at I ate dick at that one that was
like a [ __ ] popularity ABC young
comic thing well you still were you as
confident the second time you're like
they they were a stupid last time this
time Lim I was a little bit [ __ ]
dumber like I was even more arrogant
than I was the first time like I wasn't
a bad person oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is Dicky
sciatic oh I wasn't as bad I wasn't I
wasn't
I hadn't improved if that's what you're
asking right I hadn't improved and I
hadn't even tried to [ __ ] improve I
just went down there with this attitude
go behind me you think he said I went
down there with this [ __ ] attitude
that that I was the luckiest man in the
world like I was acting like like you
were the king and I went down there and
I saw 40 real comics like from that
night when I had gotten let the comedy
works
I had seen 40 guys but I'll never forget
seeing one guy with a black jacket and a
peacock okay and I looked at him and I
[ __ ] my pants like he got in my head I
just went over to the list I erased my
name they left and you know guys that
that's uncommon why do you why you used
that to scare the guy with the jacket
with the peacock on the NBC Peacock yeah
it just gave me it didn't give me
anxiety it just gave me fear like I just
[ __ ] my [ __ ] pants before I even got
to the stage so you look you were
walking up like I could get a show on
NBC I should [ __ ] it I should have a
show on NBC to go that's for you liberal
and then you see it and then you just
like the whole day I was psyched up I
was psyched up you know the week before
I had worked on my material which was
garbage I draw
down there I got a sub by that time I
was just about to get separated now
fighting all the time there was just
nothing there there was no
communications I was going home to hug a
baby take a shower talk to somebody for
two minutes and we would sleep on
opposite sides of the bed and I'd get up
and I'd do it all over again
and then one day I went home and I said
I said something I know this is just not
working I just got the credit card for
10 G's just came in the mail
mysteriously look in those days when you
take the student loan out you get these
[ __ ] credit cards but I guess for
3,000 4,000 5,000 I never touch them I
wouldn't put a diamond up I had one for
500 I [ __ ] with I've always been at
you just one target and this one comes
in with a $10,000 limit and this one
comes in would attempt to hug them now
hole in it and I start talking to my
wife at the time and I go you know what
I need what the go-go's took a vacation
you know vacation that's all I ever
wanted vacation that's it I go let me
take a vacation so I booked a flight to
New York for ten days ah
mistake number one mistake limo I didn't
know how to travel in those days I
didn't know what I was doing what do you
mean 10 days what's rule number one wait
what's the rule I tell you though you
always say short three days before you
[ __ ] lose your mind and go what am i
doing at this island I gotta get the
[ __ ] out you know at least you move
around you go to your friends up there
you come back you know after three days
I can't even go home this kind of my
booked it for ten days with a ten
thousand dollar credit card I get to the
[ __ ] Airport I go to pick up my
rental car it's a big police car well
those big white one do I take this for
the cost of a [ __ ] compact give it to
me I had conditioning a CD play I'm
living like a [ __ ]
you know little it's my intention to go
to New York was just to get high and do
stand-up comedy that was it with $10,000
with $10,000 10 days for 10 days that's
what my plan was and I get back and
George is all [ __ ] up he's smoking
crack
he's got a little Foilers windows scotch
tape so the daylight don't come in like
blade you know saying he's [ __ ] pale
he hasn't seen the Sun in weeks
oh my god and he and I'm like what's
going on let's go get the package and he
took me over by Yankee Stadium the first
night and he got me like eight twenty
fives and he was [ __ ] up and we came
back and then he disappeared and I went
back to Grandma's and did the coke by
myself it was [ __ ] horrible so my
plan was to go into the city and watch
Konami and maybe sign up for a few open
mikes I go into the city sign up and
after 20 minutes go [ __ ] this I'm gonna
get a grandma ball and I'm going on and
that's what I did I went over to City
six times and then get on stage once but
when I was in the city I saw all these
open mikes and I started understanding
oh this is way so you guys just don't do
this once a week they're like no we go
out every night every night oh you gotta
do this [ __ ]
yeah we do it three times a night seven
nights a week I go you guys get paid ah
once in a while we get 20 bucks dirty
but what so wait a second let's say you
got a gig in the Bronx we take a train
like these guys were like [ __ ] like
this this is nothing I'm like no I'm not
bored or borrowing queens for six bucks
and not [ __ ] picking up money well
that sounded absurd in my world I didn't
know about art I didn't know about hard
work what'd I just tell you like I
thought I was gonna go to a radio
station and go hey deke sigh yeah put me
up on stage get 200 people I'm a star
and that it would get out to the
airwaves and
some executive would see me and ruled me
to Hollywood and that was it I didn't
know you had a work Li work work are you
[ __ ] crazy
when that guy told me that story about
[ __ ] them going out every night how
long you been doing this for years you
could pay yet no I got a danger what
what are you [ __ ] stupid and you do
this every night every night get the
[ __ ] out of here
I'm doing blow I'm not doing this [ __ ] I
swear to God that was the attitude at
that time I had been on stage maybe
three or four many times I got on stage
once a month and two years got on stage
once a month Lee can you pick up $30,000
and if not a movie director came and
talked to you about buying the rights to
your life I thought it was just a
[ __ ] that's it just easy that's it I
didn't know that there was 3,000
stand-up comedians I thought there was
just seven of them the ones you see in
TV Richard Pryor David Brenner George
Carlin the skinny black guy from JJ
dynamite the other skinny black guy from
car wash that's it
I didn't know there was 3,000 comedians
what that time in 1991 that was the
comedy book that was a big comedy boom
that was the beginning that was right
there the big Tommy book so I get back
from New York I made me back two weeks
I'm working at Boulder Toyota now as of
what sales okay because they went back
to New Jersey that was the other part of
me I wanted to go back and see if I
wanted to move back there because they
were taking the one crew back they had
gotten a big job back there
only a little crew was going to stay
back here and do service when you just
go to people's rooms and fill the holes
and [ __ ] like that
so I didn't know what I was gonna do
that way then I'm like what the [ __ ] am
I gonna do don't want to move back to
Jersey that means I would have to switch
to probation no that [ __ ] so I said no
no no no you guys go do that job during
the winter those winters are
[ __ ] I'll stay here in Colorado
a job selling cars I went over to
Boulder Toyota and I was over both there
for maybe two weeks and at that time I
was still curbing cars
curbing cars is when I buy a car from
Dick's I act and I sell it the least I
had four you know I was more without
doing it they all in like a day all in
the day's pay so I nobly saya what's
your budget Lisa between six and seven I
go look on the book I know that you know
I can get one for about 55 if I really
work you got seven thousand dollars but
he wants 65 you don't see the ad I call
him I show up with fifty five hundred
cash he sells it to me for fifty five
hundred oh my god you got seven thousand
dollars cash and then you get fifty nine
even if you drop the 67 I'm making
twelve Lunger for the day did you have
it do you ever have anyone not want to
buy the car you brought them
no I pretty much have the pre-order
already in my mind okay that's that's
yeah yeah quick and you gotta call
people quick so I was doing that from
time to time I was helping a friend of
mine and then I started doing it so I
would go up the dick side and go dick
come everything let me your license
let's go down there and think I'll give
you 200 off the top what are you doing
today
not all right come on let's go pick up
200 just put the car in you're late for
one hour
I said you sold the car today and I give
you two hours I had I would find those
people all [ __ ] day long to just do
the paperwork for me and I give them two
hours I still made 800 for the day we
don't give a [ __ ]
three days a week that's 2400 that
nobody knows about
that's a spirit Jack you know I'm saying
2400 times [ __ ] three weeks it's not
bad that's 7200 right Y means you were
three weeks and take a week off like a
doctor you backpack and go play with
wolves and Indian people play the
[ __ ] bongos are you doing your
recreation no but that's a normal
[ __ ] Gentiles would do little to
absolutely juhi the scar and death no
not yet either 200 you might as well yes
oh yeah he said that your [ __ ] dude
just take those those like appetizers oh
I'll give me some of these if you don't
want the 50s I just give you some 200
and this portion of the show is
sponsored by star 1 edibles of debt
stars of debt these guys have been
taking care of me for [ __ ] years and
I love this is one of my favorite
all-time [ __ ] edibles right
me and Lee caught our teeth on these we
wanted to training enforcement when
[ __ ] edibles 800 milligrams 800
milligrams to let mr saye that's how we
roll tonight Hume saying somewhere
there's a Jewish holiday no what I was
saying was celebrated hey how's that
blue the the blue pot that you have I
saw didn't you see that the other night
the UN blacked him but it's a past I
bought a little bit I still got a little
left over yes so that's the I was [ __ ]
up leave for a long [ __ ] time man
then I get home I get back from New York
I get that job of balding Toyota
I'm kerbin I'm curb is Bobby pop I'm
gonna I've got it
you know this some days Lisa I act that
guess what I got two cars on hold and I
got a [ __ ] that's got 8,000 cash
and I just went and got this guy to give
me his coffee 52 oh I got a $2,800
[ __ ] winner on the cars mint but guess
what Lisa I only got two G's let me get
three real quick you know you gotta get
a cash dude right there let me get three
four thirty five boom there we go three
four thirty five I sold the car and
you're still with me let's go get lunch
and now we'll wait and it was [ __ ]
craziness but a lot of times somebody
who already had their 5 G's out somebody
already had their seven G's out I was
stuck so what happened one time was this
guy said to me I'll sell you this car
this is like in September because I say
this comment a little bit on the buys if
I could have the dough in a couple days
I go I called I had credit cards that I
had that one for 10,000 but I had
already put like seven on that trip but
this is way before that hold on one
second this was way before that
I couldn't take cash off that clock
because the wife I was with at that time
wouldn't understood so I had maybe like
three cheese and carrots and I told the
guy hold onto these three geez that's a
deposit of that Cup
don't put the call in the paper let's do
learn give me ten [ __ ] days I go
about to call buddy of mine in Jersey
and there's a financial aid thing and
all I had to do was turn in and they cut
you to check on 48 [ __ ] hours so my
plan was to do the deal 26 25 is to stay
in the check they give you right 2600
for the stood alone maybe I don't know I
don't forget to figure that's crazy was
26 25 I said give me the 26 2500 give me
the credits I took the 26 25 I went I
sold the [ __ ] car I made I think even
more it was a two-car deal and what do
you think I did I went right to the
[ __ ] college and I paid the [ __ ]
26 25 and I paid the extra big boom it
was forgotten about mr saye
forgotten about in all that New York and
all that [ __ ] like the Gentiles they
are they send the receipt and a recap of
a lot and my ex-wife sees no [ __ ]
thing now listen guys the marriage was
on the rocks at that time we were all
just waiting for something to happen you
know saying like a miracle to happen and
I'll never forget getting holed up in
her asking me did you take a loan out
without my permission and I said to why
I didn't think I needed your permission
I think although this was from my school
she goes yeah but you paid you know it
was a mild argument it wasn't even an
argument and that's what she said I
think we should separate for a while I
can't deal with this no more I don't
know what's going on in my own you know
whatever I'm looking at going this is
sad but at the same time [ __ ] cars and
[ __ ] I could start coming up I think
you're really going to work that said I
got rid of this [ __ ] nuisance
the only thing that stopping me at that
time I had no
zero debt I had paid my court
there was no debt and I had 15 cards
with $5,000 on I could sit at home for a
[ __ ] year and scratch my [ __ ] nuts
all I had to do was get rid of this
[ __ ] thing always and when I came
home and she said that to me that we
should separate I wasn't [ __ ] shot
guys I was [ __ ] they ever held a part
of me was sad but the other part of me
wanted something was eating away at me
for [ __ ] two [ __ ] years
Ethan away at me eat the Whammy eating
away at me it felt like every job I had
I was just uh it's weird to describe
every situation I was in
it was like I was in a bad dream like
this is gonna go quick
like I didn't know what the [ __ ] I would
say at the house alone I was snorting
coke and doing weird stuff at the house
when I do that [ __ ] it's cuz that wasn't
[ __ ] right like I wasn't right
thinking back now I don't never forget
what she packed and took off after like
a week man I felt like I got this love
for life again and I missed the kid and
I missed a kid being around know this is
gonna be difficult for everybody but it
was very weird it was like the weirdest
thing like I wanted this and you know
with whether she came and cleaned me and
took all the furniture and left the TV I
still remember laying on the floor with
a television a white rack and a VCR
that's what she left and there was
nothing in the living room gentlemen the
denatech nothing she took the force the
knives the kitchen where everything was
[ __ ] gun the mustard the [ __ ]
ketchup yeah that's [ __ ] up what do
you do when you walk in and they're like
what do you think when you walk into
that anything you were robbed when I
walked in that day she had called me and
said I'm going but I was at work and she
called by and said I'm gonna go by that
thing and take some stuff the boxspring
that belongs to me the pigs that belongs
to my mother you know sure okay when I
got home [ __ ] taking everything
everything everything do you call her
you go there what are you doing you know
holy at that time had been to prison and
gotten out my mother had died I had
lived in four different [ __ ] places
you know I left us Snowmass over 60,000
70,000 dollars and then God knows if
people looking for me I left Jersey oh
when you know 200 thousands got and
those are people looking for me wait a
second so here I am and a condo in
Boulder Colorado with no furniture a TV
a VCR and a mattress in a box brain no I
think she took the boxspring it was just
a mattress with a sheet like a [ __ ]
animal I think she left a few towels but
she took everything else guys and I sent
this thing for [ __ ] four or five
months before I moved that and all I was
doing was staying like I really once she
left I started going out at night I quit
that [ __ ] job being a doorman but I
said [ __ ] this I'm going out at night
I'm gone for it and I would go to places
I'd watch and I'd leave anyway never go
out nope for how long three or four
months I would go to certain places and
go up on stage because it's like
jiu-jitsu in the beginning why would you
want to go do something if you're gonna
eat dick I would get to a place look at
the audience and go I'm not going up
there there were not gonna like me and I
just get in the car and [ __ ] do nine
the other way home and then feel bad the
next day I can't whine a little but I
feel [ __ ] horrible why would I do
something like that to myself who would
act like that like that who acts like
that especially week after week for
three or four months that's I would go
to poetry night to give myself a
breather just to come to terms of myself
I would go to poetry night and Boulder
and sneak up there and through six
minutes till they threw me off of just
dirty uncensored garbage not structured
and that was
deal I come with myself for me going all
the way to this place and then not
getting on stage I'm gonna force myself
to go to the open poetry reading at 11
o'clock on a Friday and Saturday night
which is filled with losers okay so
nobody goes to a poetry reading at 11
o'clock on a Friday night if you're not
getting your dick sucked and you listen
to the poetry you're going the wrong
[ __ ] direction all right
especially the 11 o'clock at night till
2:00 in the morning you'll be listening
to [ __ ] poetry it's ugly people and
people nobody wants around
they got a Dede they've been hitting
their head with a safe something just
that's who's that a [ __ ] poetry
reading at 11 o'clock I'm telling you my
way
think about it anybody with any sense I
don't care how much you love the yards
you want to speak poet for you to fight
me over on Sunday with some wine and
cheese
you know 4:00 in the afternoon on Sunday
- one Saturday I want to come over
you're so 11 hey you with [ __ ]
quality I don't get [ __ ] brother with
blood boy do you've done if a girl asks
you to go to a poetry get to find those
days get to leave I never even thought
of these things in my world I never even
concepted this [ __ ] in my world man I
just wanna do stand-up I thought I did
at that time it was just a mind [ __ ] it
was just what I was telling myself to
stop me from doing something productive
what am I gonna become an electrician
for i'ma do stand-up comedy I'm gonna
read that book for understand the
[ __ ] work for you for for a week I'm
gonna be a comedian
two weeks you know that's [ __ ] crazy
anyway I'm making a living oh yeah oh
please I had it all [ __ ] by happy I
I'm telling you my plan was to go
somewhere get on stage somebody see me
and wished me to Hollywood to live with
Eddie Murphy for him and teach him about
comedy like I was gonna comfort l of
people here that's why when I see it I
notice it as soon as I go to a meeting
or somebody wants to meet with me and
they start talking and I see that
cockiness I go oh that was me 20 years
ago I really thought I was gonna make a
movie of Mickey Rourke after my eighth
stand-up comedy you know I'm saying like
I had this [ __ ] delusion that
it's it's crazy thick saya it's [ __ ]
crazy let me do some shout outs here
real quick me you all right
you're looking around like your mom hold
up Arnold Medina I love you [ __ ]
Margaret Oliver talking layer always
giving advice and [ __ ] watching the
same dekhta be in Colorado
Tommy P Alexander Voight Chad Riza and
Dan who let I love you [ __ ]
don't forget st. Louis helium tomorrow
night Friday night and Saturday night
two shows my 53rd birthday in Vegas
February 19th and 20th and 224 the
Comedy Store in the main room on a
Wednesday tickets are available I was
just thinking too bad we couldn't be
together on our birthdays I'm the 18th
I'm the day before you 63 I'll bless you
with you slingin dick and Florida when
are you coming back to Florida West
Florida you know there's not enough
weeks for all these [ __ ] cities I'm
running out of weeks I'm even going in
San Francisco I'm trying to go in
December like that Christmas after
Christmas people get crazy those two
days I'm trying to put pull [ __ ] out of
my ass you know have you watched the
Godfather epic I just watched one on the
plane today the first step I have them
on my iPad I just watched the Godfather
today well HBO
yeah if they bought the rights or
whatever they put one and two together
and took not the missing scenes that
were in the 25th anniversary but even
deeper missing singing Wow and they put
them together and it came on a couple
weeks ago but it was on tonight
it came on at 2 o'clock you know what
time it is Lee what time 905 yeah it's a
seven six hour [ __ ] movie look like
it's about the Godfather oh but we saw
that yeah yeah sorry but they put
warning
two together and all the points they had
taken out and it is so interesting that
what they took out was such a big part
of the movie they took out scenes that
showed conflict between the sons and the
father little things that he would say
at the wedding he didn't talk to them
too much he wouldn't take the picture
without Michael but then at the wedding
he wouldn't talk to him but then there's
a scene at the wedding when Sinatra
comes in and he tells him you got act
like a man and all that [ __ ] yeah that's
it's crazy that that little those little
things will change a movie so but here's
the beauty of right after that that
Sinatra goes to eat the other guy comes
and he goes old man Jenkins on his
deathbed
he's the conceal any of the family we
gotta go say our goodbyes and he goes
round up Michael and Fredo
look at my boy if you're gonna be taking
us you're gonna be breaking in to stop
Burger we're gonna be putting a burglar
masks got my boy tonight
and making them go and they robbed the
[ __ ] joint no so he goes to us they
show up in the room and he goes get my
boys ready to get the carburetor that's
called a hospital and say goodbye the
Jenko what a great scene and you see the
boys walking like to one and though
since Vito's there and Michael stops and
Vito walks up to I think goes did you're
a white girlfriend get a ride home and
already he's upset he goes one of those
medals for for saving strangers and he
walks away from then the video goes up
to mrs. a Michael come on you know I
love you and I care for you I already
have a future for you and he's like you
got a future for me you know run away
then then he goes in and this is old man
on the bed
he's gotta be a tease all [ __ ] up and
he see sweating and [ __ ] and he sees
Vito Vito says oh man Janko my trusted
constant he was Godfather
I'm happy you're here stay here so when
the Grim Reaper shows up and he sees you
you will scare him I mean it's a [ __ ]
powerful [ __ ] scene [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
wait say that again so he says to
Godfather's stay here so when the Grim
Reaper comes and he sees you he'll be
scared no [ __ ] leave
it's [ __ ] strong I mean this whole
this there's you know there's a lot more
parallels with him and the father like
it's too long to watch so what I did
today it was at 4 o'clock I always
watched the first 10 minutes of the news
so I put the news on and that's when I
realized it was on February 3rd and boom
I [ __ ] the coordinate no I didn't
record I put on the thing and it was the
hotel which is one of my friend like if
I was gonna be an actor like if somebody
came to me and said I really want to be
an actor joy what do I do I go first of
all watch The Godfather but focus on the
hotel scene they know when the guy says
you know I am my neighbourhood we sell
it but we control it we keep in the dark
areas they're animals anyway let them
lose their souls right after that do it
says that line he gets up he starts
talking to the guy and he starts talking
about revenge where revenge bring back
your son will he bring back my son and
he has a pen in his hand he has a pen in
his hand will I give you one of these as
a consolation prize for coming on the
show these were absolutely blow a face
you understand today I so wanted to go
into the bathroom on the plane I flew in
today and I have me cigarette and I
wanted to just take a couple of hits and
that but I I saw you I heard your story
to take home let's see I smoked a few
hits mr saye look at you you [ __ ]
honey moly like a doctor oh yeah you'll
be back at the [ __ ] cactus tonight
get the guitar well it was again what
are you gonna get the cactus you got
talk to us today nobody gonna get him up
the cactus you gotta go back who gives a
[ __ ] he's and he tackles again
funny things do you think he's gonna
give a [ __ ] I don't want that
and for once listen this is that way
it's 10:30 you know what you're getting
[ __ ] tacos okay from the cactus to
watch each other on tacos actually you
go get my three with a diet coke do you
say onion rings two words no no and you
rings the taco place but if you don't
know anything she was stopped where he
was supposed to take you to know he
[ __ ] up no we didn't have time we
didn't have time listen he's never got
time he's got more stories in the book
he had thought he knows he wants to go
there any two burgers watch them when
you see him there oh there's some
changes he slouches he gets all paranoid
like the Russians are coming and [ __ ]
like do is grab your stuff first you got
what you always go for stuff first I
gotta make sure what stuff
nuts are our fries oh no no the food is
delicious there he killed them what
Sorella fries last time two wars but no
I did not have been [ __ ] the other
garboil Johnny Johnny Rock and my wife I
just go for the cheese but I think it's
one of the best burgers I've tasted a
long time and the guy at the Charlotte
calmly his own said there's a place in
Orange County it makes the best burgers
ever had I have no [ __ ] I got my
driving orange Canada what's the matter
Lee you just saw the devil there I just
saw that shaking lawfully shake them up
shake em up shake them up shaking oh my
god Lee I had so many problems at stand
up I wanted people to know that that it
wasn't like this was all in the three
year process in three years honest I
probably got on stage thirty times like
I was remember when I worked at the
broker I got on stage every Tuesday that
was four times a month in my world that
was good enough and maybe maybe once a
month on Saturdays I would drive all the
way out all the way out an hour to an
open mic that started at 11:00 and the
guy would put me up at 12:30 and I would
die
every time I went down and would just
die I thought I was cute and I go up
there with a suit and do stupid [ __ ]
jokes and there were every time I'm like
one of these people are to throw [ __ ]
rocks at me dog it was crazy I can't
believe I stuck with it because it was
terrible guys and there was a white dude
named Bill Bauer and bill bill Bauer
there was two of them there was Wild
Bill Bauer who was really a comedian
then there was Bilbao who worked at a
motorcycle shop and well they two people
are one person they were two different
okay regular Sophia and regular Bilbao
was a great white dude he was like if
you see Americans this guy was really a
great white dude and for the first time
he saw me he gave me a gig like two
nights later and Greeley at the Denver's
training camp you know he just liked
something about me and then he would he
booked the room on Thursdays and
Greeley's what did you drive and to
Greeley it smells like [ __ ] you never
smelled anything like that like the
cattle in those days whatever was there
I was really bad so he would send me to
Greeley as a feature twice a month so I
would do for two in would I would do
seven sets a month I do seven sets a
week you know saying hey sit through 12
to 13 so for three years I did seven
sets because remember I was at the
broker friend I was at the broker from
December of Lane D to January of 92 and
do you think you were working hard when
you were doing seven cents a month I
didn't know better I wasn't committed
Lee I was not committed sometimes we do
things but we're not committed we're
just doing them until something weird
happens I'll do it a little more when
something happens you know I didn't have
any relationships with the guys at the
comedy works cuz I didn't go down there
I wasn't involved I stayed in Boulder
you know why go into those places I just
didn't bother so when you don't make
friends with those people you're not
gonna get committed Lee it's that simple
you know it's like I told you my friends
came down here with his daughter and I
explained her you learn acting watching
a [ __ ] movie once you do a few scenes
back and forth and you get the concept
that was going on and I could explain it
to a [ __ ] tart like I gotta explain
it to somebody who's [ __ ]
pathetically dumb cuz I'm dumb once you
explain that concept you're off and
running I don't need to see you three
days a week to do breathing and to make
you [ __ ] do ballet classes somewhere
else they make you [ __ ] them you
follow me you could work these guys you
see on TV ain't no better than nobody
half of them didn't even take [ __ ]
acting classes brother have them then
half of them went somewhere and decided
there buddy cast something you guys
would be [ __ ] surprised you know very
seldom all those dudes that really took
acting wanna do [ __ ] film
you know the John the Toros people I
thought they focus on Phil to get all
those character actors like now he's
doing TV because it's tryna but even
Patrick County the guy that played like
Luther in 48 hours knee was and wasn't a
bunch of [ __ ] movies he wouldn't do
TV for years but you don't need to act
20 you know would stand up you really
got a [ __ ] commit there this [ __ ]
thing was TV paying as well back then
because it was it's crazy to imagine
that saying no to that much money who
like when the people were saying I don't
want to do TV the film actors were they
paying was TV paying 30,000 and also
[ __ ] yeah so yeah that's crazy
yeah but they were also paying on those
movies too yeah but you can't always be
doing a movie
can you oh yeah if you're a good
character actor you could go from movie
the movie the movie I mean it's fine
listen Lee when your heart they want to
do business with you
and now you go from project to project
the project to project that for the dude
I did grudge match with that played the
Nero son
yes it's not working he was on Walking
Dead that he did the movie were by
Germany with Brad Pitt in the [ __ ]
tank now they just put game another role
in the series is good in that sure he's
good and everything he does that guys
classically trained New York City or
wherever the [ __ ] he's from Detroit or
wherever he's from Baltimore
he's classically trained like he trained
doing something if you started getting a
lot of roles would you do that like do
it as I'd like over and over again
absolutely who wouldn't listen
it's it's [ __ ] up to say this that
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] old too and everything
gets old when you have the freedom that
stand-up has sometimes I get a little
aggravated with stand-up let me go
there's nobody behind me there's no
punch clock there's no [ __ ] nothing
there's no nothing
what am i mad about that's gotta be the
best feeling in the world
what there's nobody here with me I even
get on this plane I like those
I either cancel or I don't I either
upgrade or I don't you know I don't I
just don't you know insane like who's
better than that I mean I never thought
that I would be [ __ ] flying out in the
middle of night like a thief to st.
Louis never in my wildest dreams I was
just killing time and then I have fire
from the broker being the manager from
the broker didn't really get a wall he
was a bar guy the guy that was at the
bar for the long time quit so he was
from the outside bar and he came in he
it's like puttin the [ __ ] Christian
in a bar you know the guy that was a bar
manager he understood the bar because he
had been in as a bar piss for 20 years
he had run like a music thing in New
York think I was always with Texan guy I
became friends but another opportunity
came up and he left so instead of
replacing this guy would
real bar guy like seven nights a week
where people hang out and drink and do
blow they replaced him with Gianni
Christian he hated working Tuesday
nights he had kids so he hated Connelly
so every [ __ ] Tuesday he made
complaints you know you guys got to get
off by 10:30 you know you're comping too
many [ __ ] drinks and he just kept
torturing me and torture me and torture
me so one night show him the [ __ ] off he
said don't come back and I was stuck and
I just like was like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do so I got on a plane and I went
to New York for nine months and even
then when they get on stage I was on
stage for maybe [ __ ] ten times in
nine months but I realized the work that
had to go is doing what I had to do so I
made a deal with myself then went the
[ __ ] Colorado and that's how this
evolved that's crazy I was scared for
three or four years guys so is this like
the time period that you're like losing
all of your like possessions like I was
just thinking about you moving around I
can't carry all that I had nothing like
that must be crazy just have a whole
life and like what I had nothing I had
nothing I went from to do that life what
can you have really all right tons of
clothes yeah I'm talking about to do the
life that committed to economy or
plumbing or whatever what more do you
need
he's I'm saying like if somebody's
giving you the opportunity to learn a
trade for example if I say to you Lee I
just got the [ __ ] contract to build a
hundred is to [ __ ] what do you call
those homes are the same no the [ __ ]
property you know three bedroom
we're gonna build 102 of those things
it's gonna take us three years you know
how to build not really you do you know
you never saw no all right so you're
gonna start picking up trash but I'm
gonna tell you what at the end of the
three years if you want to
you're gonna start at 10:50 and our
union wages and when you quit I
guarantee you when this job ends because
it's slated for three years that really
means four years was this job is gonna
be making thirty two hours a union
carpenter you're 25 years old does this
seem like something you want to do or do
you want to go to the you know in Maine
every weekend the party when you
[ __ ] friends so whether you want to
do now it's another thing Leo you live
at home with your mom
you just got your degree I mean a lot of
good is doing you're working at [ __ ]
Red Lobster what's the name of the place
see Lobster okay yes seafood so do you
want to work with me before you work I
won't want you to know so we work 724
don't know nothing about this this is a
project we're trying to make money
you're gonna start at 10:50 after 90
days you want to the Union you gonna
make 1875 it's gonna cost you 500 for
the book but I'm gonna pay for it out of
my pocket but understand at the end of
this job you gonna make 32 hours you're
gonna go on to be a [ __ ] great
carpenter how old do you not 22 you're
out of college at 26 you're gonna be
making very to Allah does this seem like
something you want to do as soon as I
tell Lee or any other kid at 26 that's
gonna take four years every sense shuts
down like as a 26 year old four years
for [ __ ] me so it's not take me four
years how about three weeks yeah like
that's what I wanted you saying like
that's what I want like instead of four
years how about three weeks cuz I can
pick this up and three and people look
at you like you know what in reality for
that job after you do two or three
houses you really get good at it it's
just RepRap edited after that it's the
same piece of wood in the same place the
same measurement the same cut the same
wall after the same one you're gonna get
really good and your Labor's only get
better you'll move
bastard but that doesn't mean you're
gonna be a great carpenter because
you're doing the same [ __ ] work over
and over in which is the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] my point being that those four
[ __ ] years I could never even
consider doing but I can never consider
going out seven nights a week and doing
stand-up comedy and now I look at it and
go if I had to do it it wouldn't kill me
because I'd be local I'd be a flappers
haha The Comedy Store the Laugh Factory
that's like stealing that's like
stealing if I had to go out every night
of the week I think I can juggle that
that's easy but you thought back then it
was impossible impossible in folk
impossible my friends because of time
because of what commit a fear [ __ ]
commitment and fear the fear to commit
to something the fear to commit in my
world in those days at 26 by this time
I'm [ __ ] 30
I already got really went to prison I
already got out of jail I already
devoured a [ __ ] marriage and now I'm
about to go in for the Battle of my
[ __ ] life the battle roll yeah with
this [ __ ] and I don't know it plus I'm
gonna go into the biggest battle of my
life deciding what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
now I'm single I got the world by the
balls
I've gotten everything behind me what do
I really want to [ __ ] do seeing
that's when I started getting happy
again right there was one of my
happiness started coming back I'm like
wait a second I don't have to work on a
roof anymore I don't have to do Dec all
I have to do is mail this woman's three
hundred fifty dollars a month and that's
it by this time the credit cards were
gone I couldn't pick up the phones I
couldn't even pick up my faith payphone
I picked it if I picked up the pace on
for the quarter and dialed when I put it
would ring to a credit agency no yes it
did they were looking for me everywhere
Lee for a year I just did blow ate [ __ ]
and did one spot a week and did [ __ ]
drugs free here
I don't know how I paid rent I don't
know how I did and I went five nights a
week in those days I would love to know
how you paid rent
I would eat valium I would sell valiums
I was selling volumes I was eating
variants I was eating [ __ ] I was
drinking four or five nights a week I
was snorting [ __ ] coke four or five
nights a week how are they I didn't I
finally got that job at selling neon
that brought me back you know saying I
was selling me on with but that was a
piece of cake for a gallon we going to a
mall drop off 60 flyers the percentage
is three people gonna call you for a
closed sign and one open sighs so not a
banging wasn't a bad game it's all about
percentages and then you just gotta
[ __ ] close them with the percentage
if you put a hundred Flyers out there
seven people in the contact you may be
fine guess what maybe five won't even
contact you but guess what happened
you put that second lunch of flies down
then 15 people kind of tactic it's
[ __ ] crazy it's the effort I'll tell
you what man I had a great date I had a
great week this week you know when I get
in from the town on Sunday and I gotta
go out again or anytime I got a notebook
that says Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday it takes Thursday
through Sunday and I put that [ __ ]
greater than sign and that means I'm on
the road and I take the Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and I put you know BJJ I put
kettlebells 11:00
I put BJJ I put podcast podcast and then
on top I put things I gotta do I gotta
get blood
I gotta call Gordon I gotta call this
[ __ ] jamoke I gotta call this Mook I
gotta call this guy and I write them all
down and as the week goes I just click
you know I'm saying and my goal is like
I'm done pretty much Wednesday night
look at that notebook and there's a
check next to everything and sometimes
you miss a check because you got an
audition or you get you know those
bloody [ __ ] you gotta had it you know
last night
uh-uh I'm paper I was doing nothing this
morning I had a run to do voiceover
auditions you follow me so who's better
luck
ms:i yeah house [ __ ] Lee's tip-top he's
in shape he's out there banging it oh
yeah doing seminars putting the podcast
gift on the world he's going to Dubai to
work with some arrows yes yes I send
them a plane ticket he's gonna go Dubai
it's not a [ __ ] podcast for Arabian
princess that was and wasn't podcast on
sling and dick and talk about how much
money they got Lee who's Melanie Lee
you're gonna go to Abu Dhabi they're
gonna fly our first class there picking
you up with a limo on top of a [ __ ]
camel so nothing happens to you no I'm
saying that you're gonna see that did
you request that you read it I have to
go back in check you gotta go check that
you want a limo on top of a [ __ ] cab
double camel or that's double you don't
give a [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ] camera I
was [ __ ] up they cut its leg girls and
they put rollerskates
they put you on ladders and there you go
on one side and your body got goes on
the other and they take it to the
[ __ ] thing Lisa you're gonna have a
good time in Dubai mr. Kutz it's weird
how your days go from zero to 100 real
quick no it's it's [ __ ] up high your
days I get into a habit I love this
habit I had to do radio last week I had
to radio they were picking me up at 7:45
which is basically 4:45 la time when you
really come to think about it I did the
gig Thursday night and I set the alarm
for I don't know 7:44 7:45 I set the
alarm for 6:00 people go why would you
set the oils for safe there's an hour
and 45 minutes what the [ __ ] is it that
you do what ended up I ended up waking
up at 4:30 in the morning by myself I
make I make a pot of coffee I got a pen
I turn the TV off
nothing gets turned on nothing so it's
even the cats look at me when I'm home
that's why ten ballistic cats look I'm
like what the [ __ ] do it do something
you're not putting the music on your now
if I make myself sit in this silence
look at leader where he is right now
what are you hearing right now pilot to
Bombardier father
oh that's good Lee you need it that you
off training for a couple days of
training where did you do four or five
punches every time when my weight yeah
it does really confirm should these
people these people confirm [ __ ] more
than anything in the world so I wake up
this morning and I do my regular stuff
they're getting sleepy this is the new
evolution of the future we are one ithi
you surrender or we will come and get
you
because that is the order of all is
I love you TVs Run For Your Lives it's
over say it's over cut second that's a
great bedtime story which was all that
was yeah that story right it's over till
it's over
yeah so it's just weird mr saye for the
last two or three like for it yeah five
it I've always been getting up at 4:45
and busting an opal guy but for two or
three years I'd put music on it and I'd
put the earphones on so I'll bake a ham
and I'd be smoking pot smoking
cigarettes and drinking coffee perfect
this I figured let me just turn
everything off and I want to see what my
mind is [ __ ] feeling I really want to
see but just my mind is feeling like I
never I just started doing this and I
got the idea from somebody said that
Denzel Washington would make himself go
through every emotion in the mornings he
would force himself and I thought how
[ __ ] unique is that the four years oh
who [ __ ] lives like that that you got
time to force yourself to go through
every emotion in the morning you know
saying like I go through two emotions
fear and I got a [ __ ] those are the two
emotions and and I'm hungry and I'm
[ __ ] hungry after that and then you
go in the shower and you bounce to that
but this is completely different this is
just to get up silence sit there with a
piece of paper and a pen and just see
what's coming out it takes about 15
minutes for you to wake up and get out
of the fuzz and by that time I'm already
drinking a water taking my thyroid pill
coffee 20 minutes in I go outside and I
hit the pipe two or three times just let
them know I'm [ __ ] there and they
periscope no no no oh not yet
no electronics oh yes but at 8 o'clock
that's not either cause oh what time was
it it's 4:45 oh my god I lost I got
there it's dark it's me and the possum
yeah he looks up at me with his little
[ __ ] eyes I hit the pipe 2 or 3 times
and it just exhilarates me nice it huh
and I finished that coffee that coffee
makes it really hot and I sit down and I
finished the [ __ ] coffee got about 45
minutes in my pen starts writing and
years ago there was the something was
way the writers way or something and
they said to get up in the morning and
just to dabble you know get a notebook
and write I tried that and it was just a
waste of a treat I don't want to do that
I want to get it out emotionally on my
own and work it out
and I had to hear what happens [ __ ]
35 minutes 45 minutes said remember what
date it was what is it it's February 3rd
so I call the little loops even answer I
left them a message I told them I love
them happy birthday to my brother's here
50th birthday and then is my daughter's
birthday and I gotta tell you something
for the last 20 years on her birthday I
feel terrible about doing stand-up
economy because I had a choice I had a
choice to be a father
fight for what was mine and kind of
choose a different path oh I had to
choose this path I chose this path and
now I don't have my daughter so I was
very for [ __ ] dirty minutes my wife
doesn't get up till Sabbath sofa
five twenty till about six twenty bro i
sat there not angry but I was preparing
the speech I was gonna call him and tell
it today like a go this is what I need
to do it just to feel better today I'm
gonna [ __ ] write a speech out and
call him and stick to that speech no
deterioration that speech don't curse
because then she could call the police
and don't threaten it just explain to
her what how I feel you know and it was
something like you know just tell her
happy birthday I called you a year ago
and you didn't [ __ ] ever tell her you
know she's not prepared to call me back
so you know I just want you to know that
you know I can't believe that you would
do something like this you know there's
some body you know cuz the whole time I
was the [ __ ] criminal but that you
can even sleep at night knowing that you
changed somebody's idea of love towards
somebody else I've done a lot of creepy
things but I would never change
somebody's down or somebody out of
somebody else you know just the thought
that you live like that you know and
someday I'm gonna get the creepiness to
hire a probably investigate er and to
look for certain things that I still
remember and then to get those in the
report and to some way gun to my
daughter so she could read the truth you
know and then hopefully she could figure
out the two and two of this story and
now you'll see what it feels like to
live how I've lived for 20 years - for
some child that doesn't know you
- now know you but not know you you know
because at the end of the day she's just
a [ __ ] liar you know I'm saying like
that but she parades herself as a normal
human being
you followed me I put my heart out in
this podcast everybody knows every
[ __ ] dime I've stolen I got nothing
to hide here she would never do anything
like that because in her world she
didn't do anything wrong Lisa at you are
[ __ ] up jack
deep into the murky waters of the
underworld he want to smoke some Moree
for the balance yet
oh you want the vapor pen the vapor
balance yeah yeah why not
anyway so that's how I felt this morning
oh my god till my wife woke up I didn't
say nothin to my wife I wouldn't have
the balls to say things to my wife about
calling this dirty [ __ ]
and you're going off mouth I'm not
raising my voice and not getting excited
so from eight to nine I put myself in a
better mood and I said I'm gonna call
her after I go take it to school if I
get back from Mercy I'm gonna go on a
walk my wife goes to yoga I'm gonna call
her and say well I have my piece and
I'll feel better and I started thinking
about it and I said what would be
calling her and giving her my game plan
how better would that help me be calling
her name's how old am I now you know and
all most of my phone rings for something
and I got amused on the phone then I had
to go meet somebody then I went through
jitsu and then I had go for voiceover
then I email somebody and now it's nine
o'clock I didn't call her and I feel
[ __ ] tremendous that I didn't because
what the [ __ ] is the difference I got a
wife I got a kid I got you I got this
[ __ ] jamoke over hey love like a son
look look at the shape of that and
that's basically let's read some [ __ ]
sponsors and let's wrap this mother
[ __ ] up till Monday that was a good
podcast Lee thank you for asking
questions and [ __ ] sometimes you got to
talk about this [ __ ] because yeah you
know people I'm when I do comedy now
last night did the Laugh Factory and I
was standing at some comment came home
and said to me can you give me advice
you know when he asked me if I was
scared he goes you looks like you've
never been scared and that really
bothered me because my fear should come
through my standup you know I'm saying
like that's what my stand-up is is
baseball that's why I go so fast by
yelling and get [ __ ] excited
you don't yell if you're normal you yell
if you're scared right when you go to
our movie the girls
right I never thought about it like that
I guess everyone else got you come off
as aggressive its run by fear it's a
fear if you listen to it and when you
don't you mean by that
you have some fear like sexually yes
well what have fears are very delete
listen to me I break your balls because
if it wasn't for any of this [ __ ] I
wouldn't leave the [ __ ] house I
wouldn't let Sun hit me I'd wear a cape
with 20 [ __ ] shoes all day and yellow
orders the [ __ ] you know Mexicans in
my yard I'd do the same [ __ ] as you did
it'd be the best life but he got plans
with the old man why are you here where
are you gonna get dumplings again with
Paul oh jesus [ __ ] christ he won't
start with have you had those yet read
the report okay anyway dumplings a
comedy show on Friday what Kobe sure you
think I don't know that I don't know I
don't know if we're gonna do it on fire
but at one point down the week movies
yeah we're gonna see Paula so which one
you see I don't know he's seen
everything so I have to I have to find
somebody relevant revelant yeah is it
the revelant yep yeah revelant yes did
you enjoy it it was an excellent movie
okay the effects were fans when that
[ __ ] bad breathes into the [ __ ]
god of the camera right was it duty yet
I think you know I left there thinking
ah this may not be an Academy Award
[ __ ] winning migraine but today I saw
him with the stick and some ad and I'm
like you know what it wasn't a bad movie
was a great movie I thought it was a
great yeah should he win their Anatomy
award I'm not sure yeah I don't know
listen let me tell you something that
English dude that puts the wig on he's a
[ __ ] lock ain't nobody beaten that
[ __ ] Daniel's sister wasn't in
that movie
the [ __ ] chick sister the guy that
[ __ ] puts a wig on that movie with
the English actor nobody [ __ ] knows
them how do you do this mr. Saur yeah no
I doubt it's a movie out right now with
that [ __ ] English kid that everybody
loves you got a nature box over there
yeah thank you my brother yo they hold
of that you see I'm looking for [ __ ]
like like a pirate I'm over here looking
at this treasure and nobody says no
God's domain [ __ ] thank you what is this
thank you no I thought it was a good
movie
yeah it was one of the few movies that
held me my wife fell asleep for about 4
minutes but it held me I like all that
Indian [ __ ] yeah killing white people oh
yeah white people killing Indians and
before I went a couple people told me
they warned me that we thought it was a
little graphic I was thinking about
during the movie how I wish I [ __ ] hit
them in the head with a [ __ ] stick
for something crazy like that it was a
good movie and had its moments
yeah that I passed I kept looking at me
all-wheel okay what do you have you
passed out in movies before pulp fiction
Oh tremendously passed out 99 [ __ ]
passed out I had to put chocolate in my
mouth to [ __ ] wake me up prop me up
in the [ __ ] chair what do you think
when you sound like when you saw the the
stabbing here in the heart like what
went through your mind fool you with the
needle why do you pass that's when I
passed out yeah do you remember what you
were thinking well it was this I don't
know when it was it was it was before
Jeff June of 95 I know that and I went
to watch it with a bunch of I used to
hang out at this place where I used to
eat for free I was a [ __ ] bum and
they would give me free chicken cutlets
and free sandwiches another mistake so I
could eat at this place called the delis
on
and I would hang out with these guys are
from Long Island Alex check out this
other muscle kid and they were great cuz
this is bold oil and the piece and
during a busy [ __ ] Tuesday these guys
got from behind the counter and had a
classic that's New York City's fist
fight so that's what brought the place
notoriety notoriety people started going
down there hoping these two clowns were
get into a fistfight everything the
place would be back paths we use fresh
chicken cutlets they deep-fry and put
them on Italian bread with mayonnaise
and salt and pepper and tomato and
lettuce and onion if you want
oh my god was Swiss cheese how much do
they cost
who the [ __ ] knows what do you think I
remember what they cost I hate like ATH
everything
I will [ __ ] mooch I was a mooch they
took care of me I would clean the couch
I would do deliveries I would help you
take garbage out and [ __ ] they knew I
was a stand-up and they were trying to
help me out man delicious though
oh my god and that's a [ __ ] a long
time ago but they were great guys they
were great what was the point of this
[ __ ] story mr. say and he was [ __ ]
high you can't ask me that question
after the that the edible and but you
look good that's all is that I do look
good tremendo good so I can sit back and
just you know take him to the comedy
store Friday night yeah that's the place
to go
where's he gonna take okay UCB theatres
do what watch him problems people jump
up and down and you got a fake giggle my
friends came you take pictures
afterwards no take them down economy
store I got three of those Cosby pills
given one maybe we eat somebody's
[ __ ] weight thing was to say I will
let you loose up in LA one of those
Persian women I can stay an extra we
show what the [ __ ] you say all these
guys he loved
he always says I hope my daddy stays oh
god he could just stay with me here my
apartment I hear him say that all the
time the both these it's like what's
that show the mother-in-law Kevin James
oh I'm sorry
so I always tell the easy fix you up
with the mother believe he should fix
you up with the we're one big happy
family and you move into a nice house in
Sherman Oaks you know Sam yeah or you
take everybody down to South Florida
with your [ __ ] take him for the
flight experience how many beds you got
there
just two that's perfect hey man Paula
and you and the mother upstairs she
cooks oh you guys wake up for breakfast
eat some huevos those Ranchos weeaboo
boobs I like my little balls I like
those crazy what I call you I remember
buddy call me you don't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about dear do I it's
nine o'clock the animals kick then it's
over 800 milligrams apiece we broke our
own church or what's happening now
record and that's how you do it people
that's how you busted open you just go
for you attack that [ __ ] anyway
let me read some sponsors and we'll get
the [ __ ] out of your hair for starters
let's talk about your experience with a
with few people let's be honest most of
your problems start with your mind right
or wrong fear anger stress anxiety
depression sleeplessness we're talking
about now they begin in your head but
they can wreck your life
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make a major difference in just 10
minutes a day this change comes through
guided meditation with the new headspace
app headspace is a meditation made
simple it's guided meditations that you
listen to whenever you want wherever you
want right on your phone computer a
tablet
meditation is ruling thousands of years
of tradition with thousands thousands of
scientific studies that show its
positive effects like improve the focus
and relationship harmony and decreasing
anxiety and stress join over 4 million
users already getting some headspace for
free right now do me a favor
download the free headspace app and
begin there take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation and head space.com
slash Joey the headspace take for the
headspace take 10 program it's a hundred
percent free way to experience the
benefits of meditation in your own busy
modern life like these doing right now
he's just sitting and meditating train
your mind for a healthier less stressed
life start your free trial today at
headspace calm that's right that test
head space.com slash Joey I got to talk
to you about this guy named Andy Pettit
combs TED talk which has over five point
five million views could you come up if
you Google and the pedicle TED talk and
he is the founder of headspace and the
voice you hear Ania you don't need to
put aside loads of time or emigrate to
Tibet Andy did that for you this guy's
was a monk for ten years here but he
knows this stuff ten minutes is
relatively easy to find but it just
takes a little effort so do me a favor
just give it a shot go to head space.com
slash Joey that's head space.com slash
Joey again head space.com slash Joey as
always you know my favorite people on
the world on it you know why because for
five six seven years they've been coming
through my life I got a flight tonight
how many how many how many how many shoe
think you think I got my bag the one I
fly with I got at least 20 of them in
the [ __ ] capsule everybody is north
you snort two of those you do what doers
with [ __ ] ginger ale boat nobody
starts [ __ ] on I'm kidding you guys
do me a favor
Ahana calm right now whether it's the
hemp force protein whether it's the
mother [ __ ] mutant exports the
testosterone booster these are all great
products or Bri does a great job with
going to the end of the [ __ ] world to
find stuff that is just right and he
won't listen they both eat that stuff
like it's going out of style I've seen
these guys eat their own product this
product there's a hundred percent
money-back guarantee on their alpha
brain correct though don't they give you
a hundred percent back then they want
the product back who stands behind your
key [ __ ] product like that nobody so
go to and combine now slash church
boom and get 10% off your first bullet
deliver it right the house alright who's
better than you alright let's talk about
something else but you all like we all
like smoking 50 [ __ ] bye-bye Nia's
and going crazy all right
and then what do you do you start eating
[ __ ] I do it myself you start eating
pretzels with [ __ ] bread problems and
peanut butter and a piece of bread with
butter
you just eat [ __ ] [ __ ] this doesn't
have to happen this way alright it's a
new year the church what's happened now
is brought to you by nature box calm and
what we do is with dedicated to making
smart delicious snack and easy you
deserve better high fructose you deserve
better than high fructose corn syrup and
red dye number 578 ask me if I know what
red dye is I have no [ __ ] idea but
I'm not gonna make you eat it
[ __ ] naturebox snacks tastes
delicious without any high fructose corn
syrup
trans fat msg artificial colors
sweetness of flavors none of that crap a
part of you goes why do I even attend
Joey you know why cuz it's [ __ ] good
the sesame sticks or take it to a new
[ __ ] planet the droplet nom noms are
to [ __ ] die for the the black and
white salt and pepper lentils a [ __ ]
amazing you understand me just
brilliantly amazing
those little coconut calm nom noms
they'll take it to a different planet
when you're high all these bags are
[ __ ] resealable so that means you can
eat three or four of them like a normal
human being unless you're a fat [ __ ]
like me and you leave two of them and
then you wake up and they need two more
and now you just [ __ ] up your
lunchtime snack and now you're behind
the [ __ ] 8-ball now you gotta go to
the vending machine no no no no no no
normal people have three or four of them
and they put the rest of the [ __ ] back
that's the beauty about nature box they
come and I'm finding in a ring car they
come in a wide variety of options from
healthy to indulge it too easy they
combine unique flavors with ingredients
you can pronounce
okay from Sorachi roasted cashews the
peanut butter nom nom nature box has
over a hundred seriously delicious
options for you to choose from all
delivered you ready for this one boom
boom sigh yeah right to your
[ __ ] door alright so say
goodbye the wind mystery ingredients and
start snacking confidently with nature
box visit naturebox.com/tyler to get
ready for this one 50% off your first
[ __ ] box right now head to nation
box.com slash joy right now and get the
right snacks for 2016 one last time
naturebox calm and get 50% off your
first box delicious high-quality snacks
sent directly to your [ __ ] doorstep
and you got to have a rings like that if
somebody steals your snack you guarantee
it's a [ __ ] fat guy with a limb you
listen a baby's got diabetes and I cut
off a toe [ __ ] that [ __ ] anyway I
want to thank headspace again I want to
thank my main people at naturebox and my
family on it I want to thank all the
shoutouts don't forget st. Louis
tomorrow night Friday and Saturday my
birthday February 19th and I'm doing a
showcase at the Comedy Store I need all
the local support I could get to 24 on a
Wednesday night 8 o'clock show I'd be
out of there by 10 o'clock all right
I want to thank honored naturebox
headspace I want to thank my little
brother Lisa yeah that always [ __ ] for
making this [ __ ] the best show
he can make right a room and dicks i hat
yes [ __ ] stay here I am
we'll have a little Pink Floyd on the
periscope nada and this [ __ ] and
please check out life in neutral as a
podcast to do the mean dry rock you are
going to a different dimension of the
mentioned
of lost but don't worry the church or
what's happening now will be back Monday
night at eight o'clock make sure you get
[ __ ] I don't care if you jump off
a cliff I'm gonna bum what you do it's
over this shows mercy by nature bugs
say goodbye to weird mystery ingredients
and start snacking comfortably with
nature bugs visit naturebox.com/tyler
take a 50 percent off your first box
John Cutler I love you [ __ ] okay
go ahead space.com slash Joey right now
and download the free headspace app and
take their take 10 program for ten days
of guided meditation